[Applause]
thank you very much my fellow Americans
I am very proud to announce today that
we have reached a deal to end the
federal government as everyone knows I
have a very powerful alternative but I
didn't want to use it at this time
hopefully it will be unnecessary I want
to thank all of the incredible federal
workers and their amazing families who
have shown such extraordinary devotion
in the face of this recent hardship you
are fantastic people you are incredible
patriots many of you have suffered far
greater than anyone but your families
would know or understand and not only
did you not complain but in many cases
you encouraged me to keep going because
you care so much about our country and
about its border security again I thank
you all Americans I thank you you are
very very special people I am so proud
that you are citizens of our country
when I say make America great again it
could never be done without you great
people in a short while I will sign a
bill to open our government for three
weeks until February 15th I will make
sure that all employees receive their
back pay very quickly or as soon as
possible
it'll happen fast